Salut les Mentalos !
Aujourd'hui je tiens la caméra à la main
Oui c'est comme ça donc ça va bouger un tout petit peu
Avant de lancer la vidéo, je voulais vous expliquer
pourquoi j'avais fait cette vidéo
C'est une vidéo qui est un petit peu sur le développement personnel,
puisque si on l'associe avec les bases du mentalisme, il s'avère que la plupart du temps,
on a les ressources en soi pour répondre à
certaines questions, c'est à dire que si on a
des ambitions, des buts, des objectifs, des rêves,
on a nous-même, à l'intérieur de nous,
tout le chemin qui est tracé:
on sait lequel il faut prendre, c'est juste
qu'on ne veut pas se l'avouer, parce que se l'avouer
ça voudrait dire s'y mettre. Et ça,
c'est un petit peu le but de la vidéo d'aujourd'hui.
Salut les Mentalos!
Aujourd'hui je suis avec Julien...
De Ruyck. *rires*
Ah tu savais pas que ça tournait hein!
Bah ouais, j'aime bien
je fais ce que je veux.
J'aimerais que tu me dises
une de tes ambitions, ou un de tes rêves,
quelque chose que t'aimerais réaliser dans ta vie,
ça peut être quelque chose d'un peu ouf, tu vois
ça peut être quelque chose de très basique,
ça peut être gagner au loto, peu importe,
mais quelle est vraiment ton ambition
moteur dans la vie?
Julien : Vivre... vivre
dans un pays étranger,
avoir une énorme baraque
sur la plage, tu vois.
Fabien: Voilà ce que j'ai écrit, j'ai écrit "sous le soleil,
vivre sous le soleil, avec des dollars."
Ça c'est ton rêve.
On va faire un petit exercice ensemble : donc tu vas
tenir la porte, et quoi qu'il arrive tu ne la lâcheras
jamais c'est très très important.
Est-ce que tu me fais confiance?
Julien: Oui Fabien!!
Fabien: Vraiment tu peux me faire confiance, je vais te demander de
fermer les yeux tout le long de l'expérience,
et de ne jamais lâcher la porte.
Julien: Ok, on y va.
Fabien: Ton rêve, c'est de vivre sous le soleil,
avec une grosse baraque, etc, et
je trouve que c'est un chouette rêve en soi.
Maintenant, est ce que tu pourrais
imaginer ce qu'il te faudrait,
de quoi tu aurais besoin,
pour réaliser ce rêve,
de quoi t'as besoin exactement?
Julien: Je dois te le dire?
Fabien: Ouais ouais dis-le.
Julien: Du coup un peu d'argent tout de même.
Fabien: De l'argent. Nan mais c'est vrai, t'as besoin d'argent pour ça.
Du coup,
pour gagner cet argent,
qu'est-ce que tu pourrais mettre en place dans ta vie,
qui te permette d'accéder
à l'argent en fait, à la somme dont t'aurais besoin
pour faire ça?
Je te parle par exemple
d'épargne ou d'autre chose,
tu crois que ce serait possible?
Julien: Ou alors un héritage?
Fabien: Ou un héritage?
Julien: *ris* Oui!
Fabien: Ouais c'est vrai. Mais là c'est des attentes hasardeuses,
qu'est-ce que tu pourrais mettre concrètement en place
dès aujourd'hui, pour ça?
Julien: Allez une épargne, allez
Fabien: Une épargne?
Julien: Ouais, pendant huit ans, et comme ça après par rapport aux impôts...
Fabien: Tu peux le mettre pendant tout le temps que tu veux mais, regarde,
combien tu pourrais y mettre par mois,
de côté, qui ne touche pas à ton rythme
de vie actuel? 20€, 100€, 1000€...?
Julien: Je sais pas.... 200€?
Fabien: 200€. Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui tu mets 200€
par mois pour ça?
Julien: Et non Fabien, non.
Fabien: Et tu vois en vrai c'est quelque chose
que tu pourrais faire, tu vois.
Ou de la même manière tu parles de production,
tu pourrais très bien imaginer dans cette production là,
déjà, projeter
un projet,
duquel tu retirerais
une vraie somme, tu vois, quelque chose de
défini, tu vois ce que je veux dire,
pour ce projet là. Et peut-être que ce serait tes
bureaux en fait, que t'aurais sur la plage.
Ce serait un petit peu formidable, tu vois.
Julien: Encore mieux.
Fabien: Est-ce que t'as d'autres choses qui
te viennent, d'autres clés possibles, ou pas?
Julien: Non pas pour le moment.
Fabien: Pas pour le moment? Ok.
C'est intéressant parce que,
de faire ça les yeux fermés,
pour vivre ton rêve sous le soleil,
tu viens de trouver des clés. Des
choses auxquelles t'aurais peut-être pas pensé, tu t'étais pas
projeté, mais aujourd'hui tu sais
concrètement quelles actions tu pourrais mettre en place pour
atteindre ce rêve. Ce qui fait qu'avec toutes
ces clés t'atteindras le rêve. Est-ce que tu peux
ouvrir les yeux?
Julien: Roulement de tambour avant,
non?
Fabien: Non. Tu peux juste ouvrir
les yeux, que t'as jamais lâché la porte,
à la différence de tout à l'heure c'est que maintenant
le rêve est accessible, et que t'as toutes les clés
en face de toi. Et tu n'as jamais
lâché cette porte.
Julien: Et eux ils ont vu quoi
pendant ce temps là du coup?
*rires*
Fabien: Ton rêve est juste derrière. Je t'offre cette carte là,
comme ça tu te souviendras des clés puis tu pourras la
mettre sur ton bureau et tu sais que ton objectif de vie
tu pourras l'atteindre un jour.
Julien: Sous le soleil
Fabien: En tout cas c'est ce que je te souhaite, mec.
Julien: Merci Fabien.
Fabien: Ça t'a plu ou pas?
Julien: *en riant* Oui!
Fabien: En fait c'est une expérience
de développement personnel associée
au mentalisme, qu'a mis en place un pote que tu connais,
qui s'appelle Julien Losa, tu le connais Julien?
Julien: Oui!
Fabien: Julien Losa c'est un pote qui est au Brésil, c'est lui
qui a mis ça en place, on peut en faire un
tour de mentalisme, qui est basé sur le thème
d'Alice au Pays des Merveilles, mais cette
version sur le développement personnel est très intéressante,
on peut faire beaucoup de choses avec ça,
si ça vous intéresse je vais vous mettre un lien
dans le descriptif, vers Julien,
et vers ça, qui s'appelle Alice est
une merveille, je trouve que c'est un
petit bonheur ce truc, et pour
l'avoir fait plusieurs fois, sur des gens, comme toi,
là toi t'avais un rêve on va dire plus standard,
mais des fois
t'arrives à sortir des choses auxquelles tu n'aurais jamais
pensé avant pour atteindre ce rêve, tu vois.
J'ai eu un mec qui voulait être une rockstar,
et tout en faisant l'exercice
il fait "faudrait peut-être que je prenne des cours de guitare...
-Quand est-ce que tu pourrais le faire?
-Dès demain.
-Est-ce que tu vas appeler? -Bah oui"
Et depuis il prend des cours de guitare, je trouve ça hyper
intéressant, quoi.
Julien: Je vais épargner dès demain.
Fabien: Tu vas épargner dès demain? Vraiment?
*rires*
Et si vous connaissez pas Julien,
et bien c'est étonnant.
Julien: Et ouais, c'est super étonnant!
Fabien: C'est étonnant parce que moi je le connais très bien, Julien...
Julien: Parce qu'il faut payer 200€ pour me voir *rires*
Fabien: Nan mais toi t'es partout
en même temps, ce mec là c'est un
artiste, un comédien, un très bon comédien avec
ce smile là, t'imagines, tu fais beaucoup de choses
derrière  les caméras, devant la caméra,
et dans le bureau de production.
Julien: Aussi ouais!
Fabien: Donc t'es sur les trois pôles en même temps,
d'ailleurs il a lancé une chaîne youtube,
elle est indéfinissable!
Je vous mets un lien vers la vidéo, vers le pilote de Monster,
ça c'était super drôle, et cherchez-le dedans,
il joue dedans. Et en plus
il y a un truc à savoir dans la
vidéo, vous savez un petit peu comme ceux qui regardent
les films et qui disent "Ah là il y a un
faux raccord!", il y a un faux-raccord quelque part.
Trouvez-le.
Merci beaucoup, si vous avez aimé ça, si vous voulez
qu'on en parle on en parle dans les commentaires de tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec cette application là, si vous voulez
en savoir un petit peu plus moi j'aime beaucoup ça
N'oubliez pas si vous voulez de laisser un petit pouce
en l'air mais surtout de vous abonner à la chaîne
c'est de ce côté là, et rendez-vous demain
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an.
À demain! Ciao!
Fabien: Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne Colombe
C'est la date, la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir.
Sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site
Julien: On se voit sous le soleil du coup
Fabien et Julien *chantant*: Sous le soleil